joining us now New York Post reporter
John Levine former Florida attorney
general Pam Bondi the first woman to
hold that position in the state and the
author of trial of the Century Fox News
legal analyst Greg Jarrett panel I'd
like to dive right into the last point I
was addressing with Professor truly John
let's start with you your report at the
New York Post the paper that was
vilified and censored from Twitter for
two whole weeks in the throes of a
presidential campaign all because you
told the truth you reported a story
about Hunter Biden's laptop and you
really paid the price as did the first
amendment how does it feel today what's
what's the buzz at the at the newspaper
really knowing that at the highest
levels xcia Chiefs the now Secretary of
State were in the fix was in with them
at the top coordinating at a talking
point for a political exercise
it's great to be with you kellyanne I
mean the word is Vindication although we
always knew it was true though
everything we published was true from
the first day so there's really nothing
to vindicate from our end but at least
the general public is now aware these
emails between Brennan and Morel are a
Smoking Gun it is proof that the letter
that they wrote saying the laptop was
Russian disinformation was baloney they
knew it was it was a political hit job
instigated by the Biden campaign and
they said at the time that this was some
organic expression of their of their
true feelings and that that was that was
bogus we now learn and you know it's
it's such a terrible violation of the
public trust because you know you expect
politicians to be political no one is
going to deny Joe Biden the right to be
political or the Biden campaign but
these are people we trust with with our
with our government and to be neutral
and non-partisan and for them to be so
weaponized in this way I don't know how
we come back from this
it's a great point and Pam Bondi you
know you've seen your way into many
courtrooms your attorney general of
Florida and a legal expert I have to ask
you though some of these of the 51 who
sign on to the letter currently have TV
contracts at other networks three of
them got jobs in the Biden Harris
Administration and I'm going to surmise
that some of them still have National
Security clearances
walk us through that
yeah and kellyanne look at their
credibility in future cases just like
you said they have security clearance
it's unbelievable to me how they can
ever be credible in any case any
investigation who will believe them
again you know we know the Deep State we
always talk about the Deep state is so
far left and this was collusion between
the Democrat Party and former directors
of our highest foreign intelligent
agency in the country working in concert
to affect not impact not just any
election but a presidential election and
they didn't give Biden just simple
talking points he used these loud and
clear in a presidential debate citing
these people that we now know gave false
statements and everything in that laptop
was real it was an incredible moment
panel because today I rewatched that
clip between Trump and Biden when
Trump's saying oh this is another Russia
hoax and Biden is really pretty angry
that anybody's mentioning the laptop and
hides behind this letter so Greg Jarrett
you've been at this for a long time and
you've been right about so much
regarding this I wanted to ask you a
little bit though about this testimony
that we can expect in the coming weeks
from James Brennan and John Brennan and
James Clapper that seems very serious to
me this isn't just punditry this isn't
just oh you you threw a presidential
election by lying on behalf of Joe Biden
I mean this thing is really starting to
metastasize
well James Clapper lied to Congress
before under oath and managed to escape
prosecution uh what's so astonishing
about all this is how easy it was for
Mike Morrell to round up 50 Liars in the
Intel Community more than happy to
deceive the American people help Joe
Biden get elected based on a lie they
completely invented the false claim that
the laptop was Russian disinformation
without a scrap of actionable
intelligence no discussion just sign
your name and we'll help conceal Biden
corruption so you know it's no surprise
that the Biden campaign was secretly
behind this Tony blinken and the
confessed purpose was to give him a
talking point to use in the presidential
debate they were dumb enough believe it
or not to put it all in writing so these
unprincipled unscrupulous people like
Brennan Clapper Leon Panetta they helped
the Biden's cover are up there get rich
schemes with foreign adversaries in what
is essentially the selling out of
America none of them have any regrets
never apologizing this is one of the
dirtiest tricks in American politician
you're right the lie was pivotal polling
data shows 17 percent of Biden voters
would have cast their ballots
differently had they known the truth so
you know these people deprived American
voters for making an informed decision
and they helped throw a presidential
election yes we found real election
interference there John Levine it is
true that people didn't know last time
but they will know this time so if
people are focused on the fact that the
contents of the laptop are real and let
me make very clear I don't need to see
another naked pic of Hunter Biden in my
life we're talking about the big guy
we're talking about the juice in there
and what James Comer is is undercovering
in house oversight so if people know at
this time do you think it actually will
matter to voters I expect Hunter Biden
will be a major major campaign issue and
trust me I don't want to see any more
naked pictures of Hunter Biden either
that's never but this has been about
that's what the Biden campaign will try
and spin this oh the Republicans are
picking on my son and he has a drug
problem like so many Americans this is
not about Hunter Biden this is about Joe
Biden and this is about whether the
president United States is compromised
because of his exposure to his son's
foreign business dealings and it's also
uh it's about it's about truthfulness
it's about honesty the President Biden
said this was fake information when he
knew it wasn't I mean he obviously was
aware of what his son was up to so
there's going to be real questions of
moral character going into this race
that he's gonna have to answer for no
question about it I agree with you
there's been a lot of transparency and
accountability to come Pam you in
addition to being a legal expert won
Statewide elections and I want to ask
you if you weren't all surprised to see
in the three-minute re-election
announcement video by Joe Biden no
mention of any of the bills that he
signed into law no bragging about his
policy accomplishments I was really
struck that she had a lot of footage of
John 36 and Maggie this and Trump that
Kamala Harris is featured 13 times in
three minutes but not allowed to speak I
thought that was kind of poetic justice
but what do you see that they're going
to actually run on to win a second term
that they're anti-maga they're
anti-republican because they have no
accomplishments as we all know in these
last years and they're going to attack
president Trump but it doesn't work
because the America First policies are
what saved this country and will save
this country again they're all that can
save this country again and you know I
applaud James Comer and Jim Jordan if we
hadn't taken back the house kellyanne
none of this would have been coming to
light right now and the truth will
prevail and I think Americans are seeing
it and Hunter Biden will be a big big
part of this campaign and so will Joe
Biden you're right those house committee
chairman and doing a great job as did
Speaker McCarthy calling the White
House's Bluffs over this a debt ceiling
I'll interview you Senator Brit a little
bit later Greg Jarrett speaking of
chairman Comer his interview with our
Sean Hannity last night was pretty
remarkable for what he said at the end
he said he knows which country was at
the center of the scheme he can't say
but I bet you will what did you make of
that
well there's so many to choose from
because the bidens were making millions
of dollars from so many different
countries over which Joe Biden had
control of foreign policy as vice
president Ukraine China Russia Oman
Romania Kazakhstan the list goes on and
on the betting line in Washington is
Ukraine but I will say that if this
latest whistleblower claim against Joe
Biden is true and if it's supported by
credible evidence I mean this arguably
constitutes bribery under our federal
statutes and a separate felony under the
Foreign Corrupt Practices Act but it
also qualifies as an impeachable offense
treason and bribery and given all of the
other Biden influence peddling schemes
with foreign adversaries it does as
chairman Comer says match a pattern of
corruption by the Biden I I think I pick
Ukraine as the likely so suspect Hunter
was on the payroll there raking in 11
million dollars you'll recall Joe Biden
bragging on camera how he extorted the
ukrainians into firing a prosecutor
inventing his son's Company by
threatening to withhold a billion
dollars in American Financial Aid the
central question is will chairman Comer
get his hands on this document or will
the Department of Justice and the FBI do
what they always do obstruct
yes they do
well I mean I thought all along Joe
Biden would be the nominee but the more
I hear about these growing legal woes of
him and his son you do have to wonder
just quickly from each of you do you
think Joe Biden will be the Presidential
nominee for the Democrats next year John
oh I think absolutely I think they're
just they're they're on this train and
the horses left the barn and they're
committed to it yes I agree but Pam
I do too unfortunately for the country
but but I think good for the Republican
party yeah Greg
they've reworked and fixed the primary
system to favor him he will hide out in
the equivalent of his Delaware basement
taking a page out of Richard Nixon oh
I'm too busy to campaign and debate I'm
trying to save America I I guarantee you
that's going to be their strategy four
for four unanimous agreement that Joe
Biden will be the nominee I'll add
another reason uh he picked as his vice
presidential running mate one of the
three people in America who couldn't
upstage him so it's not like they have a
big bench to choose from John Levine Pam
Bondi Greg Jarrett fantastic panel thank
you so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else